hello I am Zoé Halet I obtained the
British Council scholarship as a
cordial this year so in 2022 and I am
speaking at King's College London for a year
so doing an LLM in
business law and in particular the course in
competition law  since I
would like to practice as a lawyer
in competition law,
whether in England or in France and in
particular in Paris, and I decided to
go to England and London in
particular because I had the opportunity
to  go there several times, especially
with school in 4th grade, then with family and
then with friends, and it's true that
this country has always interested me enormously
since the mentality
totally corresponds to what I
appreciate, that's it  it's warm
it's ready near France and at the
same time it's a system that remains
very different as I am a
law student
[Music]
from London for a year here